former FBI special agent Nicole Parker
and IDF Special Operations veteran Aaron
Cohen all right Nicole I'll start with
you uh given this CBS uh report uh we
are inching right onto uh Thanksgiving
uh there will be a number of people in
New York City and of course as we go
into the holidays as well but starting
on Thursday with the uh I believe it's
the mac's Day Thanksgiving Parade uh and
uh the the throngs of people who come
into New York City what do you say to
New Yorkers based upon this
report you know I say it to New Yorkers
and to anyone that might be visiting New
York now is the time to be extremely
Vigilant on high alert and to keep your
head on a swivel you know as Americans
I'm a big proponent do not live in fear
we don't want to live in fear the
terrorists are not going to win but we
need to be extremely Vigilant and aware
with the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
coming tree lightings uh you know the
ball dropping on New Year's Eve there
are going to be a plethora of events and
there's nothing more that a terrorist
would like than to cause chaos violence
destruction and death at these
celebrations that frankly uh celebrate
religious freedom in the United States
you know whether you're Christian or
Jewish or whatever your religion might
be that is what this time is in new yor
New York City is the epicenter of many
of these celebrations okay and to Aaron
Cohen Ain you know um this deal for the
hostages uh a quarter of them 50 of them
in exchange for criminals jailed and
convicted in Israel and the children
that they're talking about are
apparently children who were born in the
jails in Israel why do you think Hamas
agreed to this well judge let me just
say it's good to see you again it's been
a minute thank you um as far as uh as
far as the ceasefire goes here's where
I'm at with this right now this
ceasefire I believe was initiated by
Hamas Yi sinir the leader Hamas inside
of Gaza he's feeling the Noose getting
tighten around his neck he's getting
desperate there a couple of brigades
left of uh of Hamas militants uh that
have completely been surrounded in what
we call in Hebrew L uh Israel's been
brilliantly un unfolding a pressure
cooker campaign uh using a high degree
of selectivity like tenor Cruz said very
careful uh with the civilians a lot of
special ops forces on the ground moving
house to house those tunnels almost
completely mapped out at this point uh
the dog unit oket in Hebrew is what it's
called or Calia uh the the archangels of
those tunnel operations unmapping
everything we've seen under uh the sheif
of medical Center uh senoir is getting
desperate uh uh um uh the leaders inq
sitting in those six-star hotels are
getting desperate KH Mas uh you've got
is and they're sitting there and
everybody knows that the news has
completely been tighten all these SAS
militants trying to get to the south of
Israel now and all they're trying to do
is show strength and so listen the the
hostages are have always been the key
piece for us uh uh we rescue our people
they're a big deal uh we waited five we
did it in 76 and in tby in July we got
back3 hostages uh we're in the hostage
risku B uh business and we you know
while we may not have invented it like
I've been saying uh we perfected it
Israel's really good at counterterrorism
so we're going to take those 50 hostages
back but I can assure you uh to your
previous chat with the the senator uh
Israel is going to have a very high
degree of surveillance all over Gaza we
got that whole place on lockdown and the
reason why is because Israel's a master
at that intelligence gathering so we're
going to keep an eye on everything uh
all the supply lines have been cut off
uh no one's moving any supplies we want
to get those trucks in there too for the
Palestinian people who were trapped in
the center of Gaza and so uh Israel is
going to keep a very tight eye our shinb
our mad our Aman uh intelligence
agencies and uh uh it's okay we want
those hostages back we're going to take
them but we're going to keep a very
close eye on exactly how this unfolds
over the next uh couple of days and this
ain't a ceasefire judge this is what I
call a little tactical snack of a pause
that's all it is agree agree with you
and Nicole I'm going to go back to you
on um you know with the defunding of
police with the FBI so focused on
January 6 for so long um you know how
can Americans feel comfortable even in
New York City the the mayor announced
yesterday that there was going to be a
further cut in the police uh Americans
as they go forward I know you talk about
them being free and and and exercising
their freedoms but what should they look
for and what should they be um uh how
what should they report if they see
something well first of all to your
point I think that this is something
that we talk about all the time here
there is a decrease in law enforcement
because of this defund the police
movement and all of this nonsense that's
been going on for the last several years
yet there's an increase in threats
there's an increase in threats to
Americans counterterrorism attacks and
you're right I was at the FBI their
number one Focus for the last two and a
half to three years has been January 6
Capital violence and now was the time
that I sure hope that they're dedicating
resources to F foreign terrorist
organization groups what's happening at
the southern border we have no idea
who's in our country
that is extremely danger you know I know
I know an agent who was a
counterterrorism agent and they said you
know what will you please move me to the
criminal side of the house because until
you close the border what's the point in
working counterterrorism because you're
welcoming potential terrorists into our
country it's extremely dangerous so for
those that are visiting New York City
keep your eyes and ears open you know
this threat could be a lone offender it
could be a foreign terrorist
organization group something that
concerns me drastically and that the
Department of Justice has warned about
starting last year is a drone attack
drones are extremely dangerous you have
no control it's it's difficult to track
them down and you know some people do
them for hobbies but yet they can be
dangerous you can drop explosives with
drones so just keep your eyes and ears
open if you see something you say
something you call 911 you report it to
law enforcement and I sure hope that the
FBI has their resources dedicated to
these threats because this is what
Americans are most concerned about right
now and Aaron back to you with the last
question Okay so we've got 50 hopefully
hostages coming back back we've got four
times that we've got another 150 as far
as we know over there how long do you
think this effect offensive will take uh
and will Hamas keep trying to interrupt
the flow of Israel in its uh takedown of
Hamas judge it's a good question I don't
want to speculate uh uh on the idea of
macro operation in terms of how long
it's going to take but I think Israel is
starting to put the bow on the Hamas
package here I don't think it's going to
take long but Israel's got to be very
diligent they got to be very careful the
tunnels are complex it's what we call
tubular or linear assault at the end of
the day they got to get in but I want to
talk to uh uh to your guest last answer
also cuz I think she was on to something
I want to take a minute right now I've
been training law enforcement in this
country for 20 years teaching the
Israeli model of counterterrorism and I
want to speak to every Chief and every
uh uh Sheriff out there you better start
taking your training seriously and I'm a
big fan of law enforcement but you
really want to have an honest look at
your uh at your SWAT training I know
that these SWAT teams get together about
once a month two the alert program which
is $130 million program funded by state
and federal money out in Texas and what
we saw on you Aldi may have been a
reflection of that training which in my
opinion is a little outdated so to all
those sheriffs and Chiefs out there you
better start having a good look at your
training making sure it's behavioral
based making sure you can do Point
shooting and not get on those sites when
you're in that chemical dump and make
sure that you've got counterterrorism
Based training because this ain't going
to look like yaldi ain't going to look
like uh Coline this could be several
dozen to several hundred of these
popping up right now and you get better
get serious with your tactics and start
being very honest about your response
capabilities and I'm not talking about
the big I'm talking about every city
across this country there's a lot of
them out there start getting serious
about your training and have an honest
look and ask yourself are our Patrol
officers and school resource officers
who are going to be our SWAT teams those
real First Responders are they capable
of responding to those threats under
those massive levels of stress and can
you do it in a counterterrorism based
platform you hit the nail on the head
Aaron just trying to I'm just trying to
park my car in the same garage as you
you got it and we're in the same garage
Nicole Parker as well thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else